I met you I got to see this movie theory
of everything a little while ago before
it came out and had a chance to talk to
you it was yeah that was an early
screening it was an early screening and
you and I got to chat and I was very I
was very happy to see that you and I had
similar coloring absolutely everybody I
meet in this business has a deep tan
yeah and I always feel sickly and then I
met you you look fantastic but you have
freckles the whole nine yard all of the
above this is true yeah you actually
think you like that you have freckles
you think that's helped you when you're
there have been moments when it was very
useful yeah I did it about seven eight
years ago
I did a film I was auditioning for a
film called savage grace and Julianne
Moore was playing my mum I came for the
last audition with her and she walked in
and she went oh my god you look like he
could be my son so for that moment those
freckles and pale skin and years of
sunblock yes when I there's a biography
of me this made a biopic you might get
the part better looking at Oh Bryce
gives you a giant wig and will teach you
how to jump around it'd be an ass
we'll have coaches work with you I know
I'm the dream part for you you know I
was reading about you today because
you've had that classic English
education you went to an all-boys school
just go to Eton I did I went to Eton
yeah oh boy school yeah and then on to
was it Cambridge that's right yeah no
I've been at a very lucky education and
I'm curious because you know you read
little has changed in in those schools
the in the boys schools the all-boys
schools the boys obviously have to play
girls parts that is true and that's
something that you had to do I spent
many years playing playing women and it
became helpful when my first
professional job was playing viola in a
production of Twelfth Night so all those
years of getting dressed up as a woman
were healthy and and helpful
yeah but viola is a girl who gets
dressed up as a boy so I was a boy
playing a girl playing a boy so it was
all kinds of confusing but was made I'm
very confused now actually I dunno how
that works but I I mean I know that plot
I don't dress a lot as a woman at home
but but you know we found this this
picture someone noticed your this is a
picture of you in that role as violet
and someone noticed that you bear an
uncanny resemblance to Jennifer Garner
and it's the greatest compliment of a
very beautiful woman you can also play
her in the Jennifer perhaps Jennifer
yeah all the great picking out my career
exactly yeah I've got your next nine
movies locked down you many actors are
obsessed with will do anything to get
apart and if there's a good part out
there you'll say anything to get it you
have done that as well
yeah no there was the biggest lie you've
told together hard I think there are
millions of them but it was a slightly
there was a thing about ten years ago
there Tom Hooper who directed LEM Israel
was auditioning for a thing about Queen
Elizabeth and I had my last audition and
just as I was leaving the room he said
one last thing Eddie have you ever been
in a horse
I said yes walked out the room having
been on a horse aged four and kind of
led around a paddock by it you know I'm
right and and you gave the impression
the impression that I was a bit of a
horse aficionado cut to three weeks
later were in Lithuania they've built a
huge Elizabethan Street I'm on a
gigantic stallion with like 40
Lithuanian horse stuntmen behind me
Helen Mirren is at the end of this big
road with rain machine she's dressed in
this huge Elizabethan gown and they're
attaching a spur to my feet and I'm
wondering at what point I admit that
I've basically never been on the horse
in my life they called action and I
basically went through Ocean ously down
at a hundred miles now almost killed
myself almost killed half of the crew
cleared everyone you don't know
absolutely Tom Hooper the director comes
from behind Helen Mirren with a huge
loudspeaker and goes
which was sent to a horse camp and
actually lemmas robe film I did with him
a few years later there's a scene in
which he had my character ride a horse
purely to get back at me it wasn't even
part of the plot genuinely one horse
it's actually a scene where you're going
to bed
you